is from swedish television but there are
different perspectives
to apply nato membership or not to apply
and we have to analyze all of this very
carefully as magdalena said and we will
have the discussions within the finnish
parliament upcoming weeks but i think
our process will be quite fast it will
happen in weeks as i mentioned
i think you
really must analyze the new situation do
it very seriously think about the
consequences the pros and cons of all uh
potential ways forward and i think you
have to be very serious in this work
this is exactly where we are right now
finland just made uh their riad
and we are now having the uh discussions
with
with the parliament parties in the
swedish parliament we also have a
dialogue within my party i wanted to
have this take this serious situation
very seriously and then we make a
decision no i'm saying we have to
analyze the situation to see what is
best for sweden's security for the
swedish people in this new situation and
you shouldn't rush into that you should
make it very seriously that is how i
work as a swedish prime minister of
course
it would be
a good thing if we would have the
similar choices also in the future but
there's no demand that this
is is something that um is demanded uh
but but it would be a very good that we
would have the similar uh
choices and also
um
similar kind of timetable of course
there are many kind of risks uh involved
also to the period when we are one when
we are thinking what kind of choices we
should make of course there are many
risks
and we have to be prepared for all kind
of actions uh from russia and actually
when we
have given the papers the finnish
parliament we also analyzed these risks
uh hyper threats uh cyber attacks uh
different kind of
influencing from russia's side and we
are prepared different kinds of uh
meaning
mean
meaninglessness uh that would come from
the russia side but we
i also think that that we have to make
the decisions by ourselves not uh
to have fear influence our choices
yeah i used to be against joining nato
but today i think it's
a reasonable choice i'm not completely i
haven't completely made up my mind but
it's pretty positive against uh
concerning nato right now
uh
because of the current situation with
ukraine and how russia seems more and
more like you never know what russia is
going to do so i think that should be
if it's not nato something has to be
done to make our life safer here yeah
definitely i think
russia has shown their two faces so i
think we should join nato
uh well they can give us more protection
and
our self-defense is based on deterrence
and
with nato our deterrence is going to be
so great that
it should keep russians out i think
finland should be self-sufficient so i
think we can manage on our own
yeah that's my opinion on that one